[موسيقى]
بابتسامته المعهوده تلك ترجل الامير هاري
نحو المحكمه العليا في بريطانيا ترقب صحفي
لخروجه لكنه خيب امالهم بخطوته الصامته
فهم سبب قدومه الى هنا
يوم لا ينسى تاريخي ومرهق بقي فيه الامير
هاري تحت الاستجواب لست ساعات لم يقصر هو
الاخر حيث ادلى بافادته بخمس وخمسين صفحه
يشكو فيها خنقه تجسس الصحف الشعبيه على
مراهقته وعبرت نوبات الاكتئاب والتنصت على
اجهزته بشكل غير قانوني
يوم كسر فيه هاري التقاليد مرتين ليس لانه
اول فرد من العائله يقف في المحاكم منذ
130 عاما فحسب بل لان ما عكف البلاط
الملكي على صونه قرونا خرقه هاري بهجوم
سياسي لاذع فالحكومه والصحافه باتت بنظره
في الحضيض
ومن بين يزاع النهار ان فريقا من الصحفيين
بث رعبا في قلبه وامه وزوجته وعلى الاخص
اعلامي يدعى بيرس مورجن كان يعمل في الديل
ميرور الا انه لم يكترث باتهامات هاري
مكتفيا بالقول لقناه سكاي نيوز قد اقراوا
خصوصياته في كتاب قادم ما كانت هذه
المعركه القضائيه الوحيده التي يواجهها
الابن الاصغر للملك تشارلز الثالث في لندن
وانما عبرت مشاكله القارات من بريطانيا
الى المحاكم الامريكيه التي خصص فيها قضين
فيدراليه في واشنطن جلسه استماع في دعوه
رفعتها مؤسسه هرتج فونديشن حول تاثيرته
فكيف لمدمن المخدرات اعترف بعظمه لسانه ان
يحصل عليها اسراء الصغير العربيه